now Washington is starting seeing that
old budget standoff that has shut down
parts of the federal government for
nearly 12 days President Trump plans to
hold a White House briefing on border
security for top Republicans and
Democrats later today now he is still
pushing Congress to approve billions of
dollars for a border wall as part of any
deal the Smithsonian's National Air and
Space Museum and the National Zoo are
closed this morning because of that
shutdown even the zoo's popular online
Panda cam is set to go dark Saenz so
chip Reid he's at the White House Jim
good morning
it is so president Trump has invited
eight congressional leaders to come here
to the White House today including
Democrats Republicans say they will
attend but some Democrats are still a
bit skeptical that this is a real
attempt at negotiation so we have to
have a wall as part of border security
and we're working on it
president Trump is not backing down from
his demand for wall funding but said
he's willing to talk to Democrats any
time I spent Christmas in the White
House I spent New Year's Eve now in the
White House and you know I'm here I'm
ready to go it's very important in a
tweet directed at soon-to-be House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi the president
suggested he's ready to make a deal
today's meeting would be the president's
first sit-down with Democratic leaders
since December 11th when he said he
would take responsibility for a shutdown
I will take the mantle I will be the one
to shut it down I'm not gonna blame you
for it
Pelosi says even without a deal House
Democrats will take action Thursday to
end the shutdown when they take control
of the house but without an agreement
between both parties and the White House
the shutdowns impact grows Smithsonian
museums will be closed today along with
the National Zoo and for federal
employees not allowed to work or working
without pay anxiety is high federal
employees shouldn't be treated this way
Ryan ball a homeland security employee
is furloughed they shouldn't be the
bargaining chip in this in this
important debate I mean a lot of our
work is going undone right now Baugh is
also a member of the American Federation
of government employees the largest
Union of federal employees they are now
suing the Trump administration arguing
that requiring federal workers to work
without pay is a violation of federal
law Anthony chip Reid thank you chip